Якщо ви опинилися на вулиці під час ядерного вибуху,
ваша задача перша - це вберегтися чисто фізично від вибухової та світлової хвилі.
Для цього потрібно впасти за бордюр, зайти за кут будівлі, за якийсь фізичний важкий об’єкт.
У жодному разі не дивіться на спалах, бо він може обпекти рогівку очей чи засліпити.
Після обох хвиль є максимум 10 хвилин часу, щоб знайти укриття і не постраждати від радіації, яка почне осідати.
Найкращим варіантом буде спеціальне сховище з герметичними дверима
і фільтраційною системою у вентиляції або ж підземні станції метро.
Для того, щоб убезпечити людей від негативного впливу ядерного вибуху -
радіоактивне забруднення, радіаційне опромінення -
на станції використовуються металеві конструкції, так звані затвори. Ось він знаходиться перед вами.
Відкриваються металеві щити і затвор піднімається знизу вгору і перекриває весь оцей отвір.
Це не дозволяє радіоактивним частинкам потрапляти всередину.
Люди зможуть провести в метро дві доби.
А якщо за цей час не вдасться провести розбір завалів та дезактивацію території - термін продовжать до чотирьох.
На самих станціях є автономні джерела електроживлення та водопостачання.
Навіть при відсутності зовнішнього електроживлення, на станцію буде подаватися електроживлення
для роботи освітлення, ескалаторів, систем повітропостачання і насосів для того, щоб подавалася вода.
Вода на станції з артезіанських свердловин буде.
Буде проходити повітря через спеціальні фільтри і очищатися, і подаватися на станцію вже очищене.
Та якщо такого сховища поблизу немає - укритися треба у будь-якому приміщенні:
вдома, в офісі чи навіть в магазині. Головне - правильно його герметизувати.
Що мається на увазі? Закрити всі щілини віконні, заклеїти їх скотчем,
забити вентиляцію ганчірками, скотчем, папером, ще чимось, щоб не було оновлення повітря.
Тому що якщо у вентиляцію щось виходить - це означає, що воно у вашу кватиру, вашу оселю, ваше сховище звідкись підсмоктується.
І буде підсмоктуватися, звісно, радіоактивне повітря.
Там треба мати бутильовану воду та їжу, яка не контактувала із зовнішнім середовищем.
А протічну воду краще взагалі не вживати, якщо рятувальні служби цього не дозволили.
Такі дії вбережуть від альфа- та бета-частинок.
А от гама-випромінювання проходить навіть через бетон і цеглу.
Тому найкраще перечекати за якомога більшою кількістю стін.
Ми будемо проводити оповіщення населення і казати про те, що треба робити в цій чи іншій ситуації.
Будь-яке сховище, як я вже і казав, буде захистом від радіаційного випромінювання.
Ми знаємо з вами прекрасно, що будь-які будівельні конструкції вже значно зменшують силу радіаційного випромінювання.
І чим товщі стіни, тим буде краще.
Підготувати свою тривожну валізу, мати індивідуальні засоби захисту, мати речі, наприклад, плащ,
який можна буде помити або провести його санітарну обробку для того,
щоб не принести на себе ці радіаційні елементи.
Найбезпечнішими будуть квартири чи офіси на середніх поверхах,
бо радіоактивні опади випадають на дах і на землю.
Якщо ж ядерний вибух стався далеко від вас -
треба моніторити напрямок вітру через спеціальні додатки або сайт Укргідрометцентру.
Якщо дує на вас, де ви знаходитеся, є сенс прорахувати час, за який це радіоактивне повітря досягне вас.
І якщо у вас є час для того, щоб евакуюватися перпендикулярно цій атмосфері, є сенс це зробити.
Але тільки не їхати в сторону від вибуху, тому що вас буде наздоганяти і накривати радіоактивна атмосфера.
Тільки перпендикулярно чи вправо, чи вліво.
Це найкоротша відстань, яку ви подолаєте для того, щоб виїхати із зони ураження.
У сховищі треба просидіти мінімум добу.
А щоб виїхати із забрудненої території - потрібно мати засоби захисту.
Окуляри для очей, респіратори для органів дихання і закрити всі ділянки тіла.
На кожному із цих засобів обов’язково повинен бути прописаний стандарт.
На ньому вказані усі речовини згідно з розшифровкою, з якими можна працювати в цих рукавичках.
На ньому вказано, що вони є противірусні, і, що важливо, тут вказується 421-ий стандарт,
який є стандартом, що може бути застосований при роботі з обмеженою кількістю радіоактивного матеріалу.
Тобто це часточки, це якась невелика кількість матеріалу, але це в жодному разі не опромінення.
Від опромінення товару такого немає, по-перше, він буде коштувати дуже дорого,
по-друге, він зазвичай постачається, в першу чергу, для військових.
Щоб обмежити контакт шкіри і слизової із радіоактивними частинками пилу
руки найкраще захистити щільними рукавичками з однорідного матеріалу,
для органів дихання - взяти фільтр третього рівня захисту, напів маску або повнолицьову маску
і одягнути на себе одноразовий комбінезон із проклеєними швами.
Та треба пам’ятати: такі засоби можуть лише мінімізувати контакт із альфа- та бета-частинками.
Тобто це споживчий або індустріальний товар, він не є товаром класу CBRN.
А клас CBRN - це якраз той товар, про який ми зараз говоримо.
Це конкретно радіаційний, хімічний, біологічний і ядерний захист.
Щодо вживання йоду треба бути обережними.
Під час використання тактичної ядерної зброї відсоткова частинка радіоактивного йоду - маленька.
Тому таблетка може лише нашкодити організмові.
Людям після сорока років, в принципі, взагалі немає сенсу пити цей йод,
тому що він пригнічує дуже багато органів, зуби, суглоби, нирки і все інше.
Але так, він насичує щитовидну залозу.
Його є сенс використовувати тільки дітям, молодим особам,
у яких до сих пір продовжується процес поділення клітин,
тобто вони зростають, для того, щоб блокувати імовірну негативну дію радіоактивного йоду.
Дорослим йод варто вживати лише в разі аварії на атомній станції, і те - якщо знаходитеся близько.
Про подальші дії будуть сповіщати рятувальники.
Зв’язок пропаде, але працюватиме аналогове радіо. Тому краще мати таке вдома.
Але ймовірність аварії на атомній станції чи тактичний ядерний удар по Україні
експерти вважають малоймовірним.
Вірогідне використання цієї зброї десь не в густонаселених містах, не в Києві, не у Львові.
Десь по периметру лінії зіткнення, можливо там на Чорному морі для того,
щоб запустити та подивитися на реакцію світу -
як цивілізований світ відреагує на ці дикунські абсолютно дії Росії.
Та якщо Росія наважиться застосувати ядерну зброю -
треба загерметизуватися і чекати вказівок від ДСНС.
Тоді шанси не лише вижити, а й залишитися здоровими - будуть дуже високими.